today on the matt well show we often
hear especially from the left that
slavery is america's original sin
it's the reason why we're supposed to be
overcome with guilt as americans and
constantly apologizing but today i want
to talk about i want to talk about this
idea of slavery as original sin
and explain why it's totally wrong also
our five headlines including biden's
move to ban
menthol cigarettes the democrats want to
defund the police
while also passing more petty laws for
the police to enforce
maybe a little bit of a conflict there
speaking of the police a teacher in a
zoom call berates a student for saying
that police are heroes
we'll play that for you in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the truly
insane and almost unbelievable story of
the jeopardy contestant
who issued a public apology after being
accused of racism
for holding up three fingers talk about
that today and a lot more
on the matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now word from a new sponsor trust and
will we're very happy to have
on the show and you know it's really
important because if you
uh if you're an adult you have a family
especially it's uh
extremely important to have a will this
is this is a moral responsibility to
have something
that you can leave behind to have this
all sorted out in case anything happens
to you so that your family isn't left
dealing with the mess at trustedwill.com
setting up an estate plan is simple
convenient and secure for as little as
39
you can nominate guardians for your
children determine who gets your stuff
and plan for future medical care all
from the comfort of your home trusted
world documents are designed by estate
planning experts and customized for the
state you live in
and with live customer support seven
days a week trustingwill.com team
is available to answer any questions
that you have while setting up your plan
trusted will is the most trusted name in
online estate planning the category
leader on trustpilot and
they've helped hundreds of thousands of
people protect their family assets and
legacy
so you can gain peace of mind at
trustandwill.com10 off
plus free shipping of your customized
legal documents don't wait go right now
don't put this off anymore you put it
off for long enough this is really
important get 10 off plus free shipping
at trustandwild.com
walshtrustandwheel.com walsh during
senator tim scott's republican rebuttal
to joe biden's speech on wednesday night
he used a term that comes up quite often
in our political discourse these days he
spoke albeit in a
sort of hopeful positive forward-looking
context
about america's original sin here's that
part again
i am more than hopeful i am confident
that our finest hour is yet to come
original sin is never the end of the
story
not in our souls and not for our nation
the real story is always
redemption the original sin that he's
referencing
is of course slavery we hear quite a lot
about this
supposed national original sin but
whereas tim scott wants to move on from
that sin
and live in the present most of the
people who speak of it
don't wish to move on they want to
obsess over it they want our society to
revolve around it
they want to keep our gays directed at
it they want americans white americans
anyway to feel immense guilt for it and
to constantly beg forgiveness
and to feel only shame when they think
of our history as a nation because of it
the message from politicians the media
hollywood the school system
all the all other institutions even the
churches now is that america is a
country rooted in
oppression racism and bigotry and
although those sins
can never be expiated we white americans
anyway must keep trying must keep
atoning
must keep groveling on our knees and
self-mortification
a couple of days ago representative
ayanna pressley who really
hates this country perhaps more than
anyone else in congress and their stiff
competition for that title
spoke about the chauvin verdict but
began with a soliloquy about about
america's original sin or sins
and how we still have not overcome those
sins even today
here's what she said let me just stop
for a moment and just um
be blunt and talk about how we arrived
here
black lives have not mattered they've
not mattered since the very inception of
this country
the original sin of slavery
and so for that reason because black
lives have not mattered our humanity has
never been seen
that is why our black children are
adultified that is why our skin color is
criminalized
that is why our very existence is
criminalized
now if you're like me you heard her say
adultified
and thought wait did she just say
adultified
she did and um and i now know after
googling it that
adultification is when children are
exposed to things that are too mature
for them
and are treated by society as if they're
older than they really are now this is
indeed a real problem in our society
i don't think we need a word like
adultification to describe it but um it
is a real thing we can start with the
fact that many kids as young as eight
and nine
are accessing hardcore pornography on
sites like pornhub
um but as we know everything has to be
about race
these days so the people who use the
term adultification or adultified
they usually mean it in a racial context
and will claim that it's a problem
which especially or only affects racial
minorities
forget about those dumb white kids we
don't care about them
uh this is all uh a problem among racial
minorities only
and they're probably right that it does
affect
um racial minority children
in a in a in a somewhat unique way just
think of adam toledo 13 years old out in
the streets at 3am
hanging out with a 21 year old
gangbanger playing with a loaded gun
shooting at cars
many such cases in our cities among
minority children
but who's to blame for that if children
are exposed to things they shouldn't be
exposed to
and allowed to act in ways they
shouldn't act
i would say the blame begins with
oftentimes the parents who may not be
caring for
and looking out for their own children
ayanna presley and her fellow race
hustlers would however
put the blame on white people somehow
it's our fault
if a black father abandons his family
and the mother
allows her child to join a gang
or or go out and hang out with gangs at
3am
the rest of what you heard there was
equally nonsensical and false
a black person's existence is not
criminalized
presley is hallucinating and she's not
alone she's part of the largest group
hallucination in history the entire
american left is experiencing
it but but back in realityville black
people are not arrested and charged
with the crime of being black what
you'll find in most every case is that a
black person in prison is there because
they engaged in some sort of criminal
activity same reason every white person
most every white person is in uh is in
prison
you know it's activity that that would
be just as illegal if a white person had
done it
there is no black person currently in
jail on charges of being black
that's not happening in america presley
is telling fairy tales
she may as well be reading us snow white
in the seven dwarfs
her version of reality is about as real
as that
but what about this idea of america's
original sin
i think there's a few points to be made
about that
first no slavery
is not america's original sin slavery
was
a sin a big one but it's not
america's original sin the original sin
of every american just like every other
member of every other country
is original sin our original sin is
original sin
at least according to the christian
doctrine if you're not a christian
and don't subscribe to any traditional
religion at all then the concept of
original sin
just makes no sense the concept of sin
generally makes no sense in that case in
fact
if you're a moral relativist as most
leftists are then morality is determined
by
culture and environment and by the
subjective experience of each individual
and that all means that slavery was not
actually a sin to the cultures that
didn't consider it a sin
slavery is a sin now because we see it
that way
but it wasn't a sin to the people who
did not see it that way that's the
implication
of moral relativism that's the funny
thing about moral relativists they're
the primary ones going back and
condemning people in history
but they have no basis upon which to do
it
by their own philosophy
most of the evil things done in history
weren't really evil
by their own way of looking at things
because the people doing it didn't see
it that way
so to review if you are a christian
then you know that our original sin is
original sin as described in the bible
it predates american slavery indeed
slavery is a result
of original sin a product of our fallen
nature as humans it's not itself the
original sin
but if you're not a christian and don't
really subscribe to any monotheistic
religion at all
then the whole concept of original sin
has no basis in meaning
whichever way you go nobody should be
calling slavery
the original sin with that said
if slavery is any sort of original sin
it is the original sin or an original
sin of the whole human race
okay slavery was an institution
everywhere across the whole world for
thousands of years slavery existed in
north america
all over north america before the white
man even showed up
not just slavery but slavery in perhaps
its most brutal and violent form as
slaves especially in mesoamerica
often met their end on the sacrifice
stone when their hearts were ripped out
of their chests
and their limbs were hacked off and
sometimes eaten
america didn't invent slavery america
bears no special or unique
guilt for slavery what's unique about
america in relation to slavery is that
we abolished it so quickly less than a
century after our official formation as
a country
whereas other countries on the globe
took millennia to do it
some places still have not really
effectively abolished
slavery see the real reason that people
like presley call slavery our original
sin
is because they want to give the
impression that we essentially invented
the practice
and some on the left the you know really
ignorant ones
actually believe that and we'll say so
but that's a lie
it's one of the many lies that has
turned us
into one of the most guilt-ridden
countries on the face of the earth
few nations are as focused on the sins
of its past as we are
is that because other countries have no
sins
obviously not many of them have done
much worse
and done it for much longer yet they
live in the present and we stay
stuck in the past most countries the
functional ones anyway you know they
have their national heroes
their national myths their stories their
triumphs
their sources of pride and patriotism
even if their heroes weren't perfect and
their stories were more complicated than
they
tend to acknowledge it's good that they
have those things it provides a sense of
shared identity and history and
accomplishment
it grounds them in the present as a
people as a nation
but here we've torn down all of our
heroes tossed out our myths
rewritten the stories and it's had the
intended effect
which is instead of binding people
together as one nation with a shared
heritage and identity it divides us
balkanizes us
deprives us of what we need to be a real
functioning
country and society a nation that that
hates itself can't
thrive and ultimately can't survive
a nation that hates itself for you know
no real reason
a nation obsessed with with sins from
centuries ago
sins that the whole human race shares
and yet no other country worries about
or talks about
that sort of nation will not only fail
to survive but will be driven into
collective madness before the end comes
and that again is the point it is the
intended result
it's what people like ayanna pressley
are trying to do
that's the game and our only hope is to
realize that it is the game
and stop playing it before it's too late
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now check it in with our friends over at
moiq you know uh
there's a move right now trying to get
you to stop eating meat
eat bugs eat uh grass and leaves like
some kind of cow i don't have the diet
of a cow i eat the cows okay that's what
that's what i believe in
and moique you know they deliver
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb
pastured pork and chicken and wild
caught alaskan salmon
directly to your door helping family
farms become financially independent
outside of big agriculture so that's a
good cause they're supporting along with
getting delicious delicious meat
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and moint
meat is
free of antibiotics hormone sugar and
all the other junk you find in
pre-packaged
stuff in the meat aisle and everything
sign up at monkbox.com
wallace to get a year of ground beef for
free and then pick what meats you want
delivered
with your first box that's a good you
know at my house we eat like 14 pounds
of
ground beef a day literally so that's
something we need moyk was founded by
8th generation farmer who was featured
on shark tank host kevin o'leary said
it's the best bacon he's ever tasted i
can attest to that
it really is so join the movement today
go to monkbox.com
walsh right now and listeners to my show
get free ground beef for a year
that's one year of the best ground beef
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
spelled
m o i n k box.com walsh that's
monkbox.com
walsh um yeah i do realize
if you're watching the show right now on
dailywire.com or youtube
um you've probably noticed that polka
dot friday
sadly today was cancelled mostly because
i forgot
the polka dot shirt um
and you know what i'm not gonna
apologize for that
i don't think i owe an apology and
here's what's gonna happen i just can't
win
this is how persecuted and victimized i
am personally
that first i get attacked for wearing
the polka dot shirt
and now i'm gonna get attacked for not
wearing it you know
this is this is the uh the the
persecution that i
that i suffer and that frankly all polka
dot wearers
suffer on a daily basis and it's not
talked about enough
all right this is from cbs uh says the
bible administration announced this
intention thursday to ban
menthol cigarettes and flavored the
menthol cigarettes and flavored cigars
including menthol
reading now from a statement from the
fda commissioner janet woodcock
she says quote banning menthol the last
allowable flavor in cigarettes and
banning all flavors and cigars
will help save lives especially among
those disproportionately affected by
these deadly products
with these actions the fda will help
significantly reduce youth initiation
increase the chances of smoking
cessation among
current smokers and address health
disparities experienced by communities
of color
low income populations and lgbt
individuals what
how how do we how do we how did the lgbt
individuals get involved here
so menthol cigarettes
um especially popular among black
americans so that's how
that that's that's how they're included
but lgbt individuals
this is just for leftists it's a reflex
once they start naming the victimized
groups they throw them all in there
because why not
um the fda appointed a study suggesting
that a menthol ban would help people
quit smoking
noting that menthol makes tobacco more
palatable and facilitates progression to
regular smoking
the fda said one study suggests that
banning menthol cigarettes
in the u.s would lead to an additional
90 923 000 smokers
quitting including 230 000 african
americans
and then it goes on last year the house
passed a bill
banning all flavored e-cigarettes and
menthols but the legislation didn't pass
the senate
the bans will not be put in place
immediately since they're subject to a
potential years-long rule-making process
matthew myers president of the campaign
for tobacco-free kids
said that the move would be historic and
protecting kids from tobacco addiction
and advancing health equity
particularly among black americans
health equity
now um
there's plenty that can be said about
this but let me let me focus on one
aspect of this
and i've commented before about the
perversity
of having specifically our lawmakers
constantly attacking and undermining our
law enforcers
because that's the situation you want to
talk about a a non-functional society
well this is how you get a
non-functional society and especially a
non-functional government
when you've got the people making laws
throwing the people enforcing those laws
directly under the bus
for enforcing those laws
and dealing with ramifications
so here is a classic example of that
where this is a this is a move supported
mostly by i'm sure plenty of republicans
are going to sign on board with it
uh because they love the nanny state bs
also but this is a move we're getting
from the buy administration and from
democrats
banning menthol cigarettes and what does
that mean now
yes they're going to try to enforce this
before it gets to the consumer level
but there's also going to be we we can
assume some consumer level enforcement
what is that going to entail exactly
well who knows we'll find out
but this is all you're doing is you're
you're giving petty nanny state laws
for the cops to enforce on some level
and that's how you end up with a lot of
these cases that
that often are wrongly described as
police brutality
the cops are doing their job they're
trying to enforce a law
the person that they're that they're
dealing with responds violently
and then the cops have to escalate in
response and uh then next thing you know
there's rioting in the street
rinse and repeat over and over and over
again
think about the uh what was it the eric
garner case
in i think that was in new york
and uh he died during the process of an
arrest
and the the crime that he had committed
was uh was he was selling loose
cigarettes
okay well that's now if you don't want
the cobbs
loose cigarettes meaning he he bought a
pack and he was selling individual
cigarettes
that's against the law apparently and at
least it was in new york
now if if you don't want the cops
arresting people for that
and if you don't if you don't if you
can't tolerate the possibility
that even some citizens will die in the
process of that enforcement
then don't pass the law
but if you pass the law i've seen people
put it
i think a good way of putting it is if
if you don't
if you don't want people to die over
this potentially then don't pass the law
doesn't mean we should have no laws but
when you're passing a petty nanny state
law
stopping people from selling a you know
a single cigarette for 50 cents or
whatever they're doing
or smoking menthol cigarettes then don't
pass it
that's what democrats do they pass a
whole bunch of these of these kinds of
laws
they send the cops out to enforce them
cops do that
and it gets messy enforcing laws is a
messy deal
it's not like um and and you could say
well they're
just enforcing the law doesn't mean you
go kill someone for eric
the the you know the lawmakers never
said that you should go execute a
citizen for
selling um loose cigarettes well yes
right but that's not what happened
they're trying to enforce it the person
they're dealing with is resisting that
enforcement and then what do you do
do you just say okay well never mind if
you don't want this law to be enforced
on you then we're going to go home
forget it
sorry to have bothered you sir
no they're resisting now you have now
the state has to impose its will
if it's not willing to impose its will
then again the law shouldn't be there
and that's how the escalation happens
and sometimes it gets
it turns deadly
and often the faults for that doesn't
fall on the cops it can fall on the perp
and it also falls on the lawmakers who
made those laws to begin with
all right um it's it's just like the
the case another case dante wright
you know we were told initially and we
know this is false now but we were told
initially that he was pulled over for
uh having an air freshener air freshener
in his car
and people were saying how absurd it is
that somebody would be pulled over for
that
well that's not what actually happened
right so
that that was a falsehood he was pulled
over i think it was
uh i forget there was some other traffic
violation he was pulled over for
originally and then they found out that
he had a warrant for his arrest
stemming from an armed robbery and they
tried to arrest him as you do with
someone with it with a wanted armed
robber
but even if it was let's just pretend
for a minute that he was pulled over for
having an air freshener hanging from his
car well who would you blame for that
see the democrats in the left they were
blaming the cops and why would you pull
someone over for that
they didn't pass the law if there is a
law against having an air freshener
hanging from your car don't blame the
cops
blame the idiots who passed a law like
that
you know do we do we wanna are we saying
the cops we're gonna put them in a
position where they decide what laws
they enforce
is that is that the kind of police
reform we want
all right number two speaking of the
cops a student at cypress college was
in a zoom class and he was trying to
explain to his teacher
why it's okay for cops to be portrayed
positively in children's shows and why
cops even our heroes
and i don't know listen to this
discussion this is a student
and a teacher and you tell me who is the
more reasonable one
which are the people here if you had to
pick one to be the teacher of the class
which one would you choose
let's listen uh i think cops are heroes
and they have to have a difficult job
but we have to have
all of my life not i mean
i'd say a good majority of them you have
bad people in every business and every
yeah yeah wait wait wait wait police
officers have committed atrocious crimes
and have gotten away with it and have
never been convicted of any of it
and i say the person who has family
members
who are police officers yes
i i understand um and
this is what i believe this is my
opinion and this is you know not popular
to say but
uh i do support our police we have bad
people and the people that do bad things
should be brought to justice i agree
with that but i think that
uh say i'm saying it again they haven't
well i agree with you on that point of
they should right so what is your bottom
line point you're saying police officers
should be revered
viewed as heroes tv shows with children
i think they are heroes in a sense
because they come to your need and they
come and help you
and they have a problem just like every
other business but
we should fix that but i think they're
they're heroes
well they're i think that's the problem
looking at it as a business because
they're actually supposed to protect
and serve yeah it actually that's
it it gets even worse from there
but the question we started with here
who do you think is the more reasonable
one in that exchange if you had
if you had to hire one of those people
to teach a class who would you choose
so i'm choosing the student here he is
here's the student
talking to a college professor and
trying to explain trying to break things
down
in a very logical way and say
what he's trying to communicate and he
did a good job of communicating it
uh is that policing is a noble line of
work
many cops do the job heroically there
are some bad ones and they should be
punished
that's it that's the whole thing
and this somehow uh confuses her
she doesn't understand what what what
he's trying to what he's trying to get
across
but think about how sad it is
that you know you notice how he
qualified the statement i don't blame
him for doing that
but he said uh you know this is not a
popular opinion but
most cops do a good job that's not
he's right it's not a popular opinion
but that that this is what is
controversial now to say something like
that
that you know i can remember 10 years
ago
even seven or eight years ago when
everybody thought that
it used to be popular across the whole
political spectrum
to celebrate police officers
and back in those days nobody ever
claimed that every cop was good it's
just we
we generally understood that it's a
tough job we
society needs people to do this job and
we respect the people who do it
this is uh but you send your kid to
college
this is what you're paying for plunging
into yourself
or your child into potentially decades
of debt
for that all right number three this is
from the new york post
it says a seven-year-old is a terrible
story a seven-year-old girl was killed
and her mother injured after pit bulls
attacked them in a north carolina
backyard
the mother and daughter were taking care
of their neighbors two pit bulls
and at one point they attacked
garner police lieutenant michael mciver
says
this is a horrible tragedy for all
involved our thoughts and prayers go out
to both families and all those who
responded
their dogs were reportedly taken to an
animal shelter and it's unclear what
sparked the fatal attack
you want to talk about unpopular views
here's here's one of my
many unpopular views that
uh it it's i think it's
ridiculous and reckless to own pitbulls
i do i do think pit bulls should be
banned
from communities and neighborhoods
hey this you see these kinds of stories
every year
huh yeah most pitbulls aren't out
mauling people but they're
pitbulls are perfectly capable of
mauling especially a child to death
and you're just kind of hoping if you
have a pit bull that they're not going
to be one of the pitbulls that does that
and you and how do how do you achieve
that it's by
it's by suppressing their innate
wild aggressive nature and if you don't
appropriately suppress that
then they're gonna maul a child to death
i guess i don't understand why take that
risk
there are there are a couple of dog two
or three dog species that are
responsible for pretty much all of the
maulings
and all of the deaths what
why take that risk if you really feel
the need to have a pet in your house
why choose one that could if it decides
to
kill a child in the neighborhood
i need a good reason is if your reason
is well i think the animals are cute so
is that a good enough reason to take
that risk
i just don't i don't get it i don't
understand
bringing pit bulls your hope and what
you always hear from pitbull owners
right is well my my my pity would never
do that
you don't know what your pitbull will do
it's a dog
it's an animal you know almost nothing
about what's going on inside
that creature's head it's a mystery dude
it's a mystery to everybody
it could snap at any time if it wanted
to and if it decides to it could kill
somebody
or disfigure them for life
i don't see it i don't see the point all
right um i want to play this for you one
of chauvin's
one of the the jurors in the chauvin
trial was interviewed by cbs
and he said that he felt no pressure to
reach a guilty verdict
uh and here's how he explained his his
reasoning let's watch
did you feel pressure because you knew
the world was watching that
you know we have to reach a guilty
verdict here
not at all and i don't think i don't
think any of us felt like that um
i for sure did not i for sure did not
feel like that
um the pressure more so came from just
being in the room and being under stress
but it wasn't pressure to come to a
guilty verdict
we were just stressed about just the
simple fact of i mean every day we had
to come in and watch a black man die
that alone is stressful yes okay so
so maybe that's true um i don't know
it's what he has to say of course the
jurors can't come out and say oh yeah we
only did this because we're under
pressure
obviously they're not going to say that
they can't say that
um so who really knows i will say that
i i would find it more believable
if he said something like yeah i felt
pressure
uh but we put that to the side and we
got down to work
see that that i'd find more believable
but claiming that you felt
no pressure none felt no pressure at all
while there are mobs in the street in
your own community that you have to
drive by and through on your way home
every day um
threatening to to to burn down the city
explicitly if there's not a guilty
verdict
i just find it difficult to believe that
you would feel no pressure at all it any
human would feel pressure
so it's not weakness i would feel
pressure any person would feel
pressure whether or not you caved to it
as a different story but you would
certainly feel it
so when you hear from the jurors i'm
starting to hear now that oh no that
wasn't a factor at all we didn't even
that we didn't even notice
uh i i i i find that very hard to
believe
does that mean even if they're
being dismissive of the pressure
and uh not telling the full story there
does that mean that they
reach their conclusion because of the
pressure no but
it's still it leaves it leaves that
question unanswered
all right finally studyfinds.org
reports this despite its negative
reputation a new study finds
that gossip can actually be a good thing
for people to spread so gossip is good
according to a study
study authors say gossip isn't just
about passing on rumors and saying bad
things about others in fact
their report reveals it also serves to
create social connections and even helps
people learn new things
and the world um about the world that
they haven't experienced for themselves
so gossip is a it's it forms social
cohesion it's a good thing
go out and gossip about your co-workers
and your neighbors and everything it's a
perfect thing to do
the only reason i read this is that it
actually rings somewhat true to me
you know i've always thought about
gossiping
and the reason why gospeling is common
among women
is that is that they're they're more
empathetic than men
generally so gossip to me
is kind of like the the it stems
maybe from a positive
instinct of empathy and gossip is kind
of the ugly side of empathy
because when you're gossiping about
somebody even if it's negative the point
is you
you care about what's going on inside
the person's life even in a negative way
so there is there's sort of an element
of empathy it's like empathy turned
upside down
um kind of like hate is is you know the
other side of love
now for me i know that i don't gossip at
all really
but i realize that the the reason is not
because i think gossip is wrong although
i do think it's wrong
it's that i just don't really care
what's happening in anybody else's life
so when you come up to me and gospel
says hey guess what's happening with
this person
yeah i know it's wrong to gossip but
also i simply don't care what's
happening in that person's life at all
so don't tell me about it
so that's my that's sort of my defensive
gossiping i guess in case you were
curious about it
uh all right let's go to reading the
youtube comments this is uh
engineer or bust says matt walsh's hair
is too shiny and prim
these days i miss when he looked like a
maniac and was ranting in his car
you know i like to think i still look
like a maniac and i'm still ranting even
if not in the car
the spirit of those days is still within
me
um oh wait a second they just put it up
on the screen i forgot i almost i moved
on to the comments i forgot we had
another
we had another tick tock video we have
to play i can't believe i forgot this
thank you control room for reminding me
um yes we have another tick tock video
tradition now and there's so many
there's something we got to play more
than one a day sometimes to get all
these videos out here
uh here's another one and uh this is i
believe an ode
to fouchy that we all are now going to
experience
here it is
[Music]
[Music]
they call you sleepy but you're pretty
woke
i'm so tired of quarantine
mr biden please
[Applause]
[Music]
i think he does the entire song
this is the first time i've actually
watched the entire thing um i i saw
one second of it and okay we can turn it
off i still hear it
please please stop get that out of my
ear
i watched one second of that really and
i knew that it was something i had to
inflict on the audience
but i hadn't watched more of it than i
just did
i wasn't expecting the sexual undertones
there
but there they were
this is i you know the people who are
making these
these songs about
vaccines there are odes to vaccines
and dr fauci
what would they have thought about
themselves
like in the year 2019 if someone had
shown
them in a crystal ball that this is what
they would be doing in a year and a half
it is uh pretty disturbing stuff but
there you go
you're welcome all right uh moving back
now to the youtube comments here's
another one says
hey matt love your show if a man is not
attracted to a woman sexually but they
share
common interests why can't they be
friends
well yeah we talked yesterday about why
men and women can't be friends but there
there is some qualification to that
statement like i said that uh in in in a
many women can be friends in certain
contexts
in when when it's kind of mediated right
married couples are friends and each
member of each couple is friends with
each member of the other uh so that's a
way where men and women are friends
it could be friends they could they
could get along as friends at work
what i'm really talking about are are
you know a deeper friendship
bond like a fraternal bond
is it possible for a man and a woman to
have a deeper
platonic fraternal bond
um that involves especially them getting
together one-on-one outside of these
kinds of contexts
and there i'm saying no it's not really
possible but when it can happen like
you're talking about here what if
they're not
what if a man's not sexually interested
in the woman
even there i don't think it really works
but if it does
it's because as i said yesterday it's
sort of like the man
is is seeing the woman as another man so
if
he can make it work if he almost sees
her that way
if he can fit her into the context of a
man-man friendship
um and that's why you hear the
women who talk about how they have a lot
of male friends a lot of times they'll
talk they'll brag about all the manly
type things they like to do
because that's what they have to do in
order to fit in is to sort of
pretend to be a man um
at least for the purposes of the
relationship
another comment says i see no problem
with being anti-abortion and also
anti-elephant slaughter humans are
morally more significant than elephants
but elephants are arguably higher on the
continuum of living beings shall we say
than are cows pigs or chickens yeah i
have no problem with that
um i have no problem with any aspect of
that that's not how i feel i don't
really care if people handle elephants
frankly
but i can totally respect that
as long as you are pro-life for humans
and you also understand that there is a
hierarchy or as you say continuum of
living
beings but i agree with you that there
is an implication there where it's not
like
okay if we say that human beings are the
most valuable and the most significant
life forms on earth which they are
it's not like it's human beings and then
every other life form is lumped together
in terms of their importance and value
and all of that
well we know that's not the case i think
everybody would agree that you know
a gorilla is more important than a
cockroach
almost nobody gets upset when you step
on a cockroach
if you just walked up to a gorilla and
shot it in the head i think most people
would would be upset about that
so yeah um so i'm fine with that and
then if you say that you know as you get
higher in that hierarchy
it becomes more morally problematic to
kill those animals yeah that's
that's understandable i think that's a
perfectly rational
viewpoint um was there another one
okay here's one more says uh fine i'll
be banned but matt
matt has entered jerk dumb here with his
take on children covet vaccines
the vaccines aren't for keeping the kids
from getting sick therefore making sure
those mobile petri dishes become a part
of herd immunity so their grandparents
can visit them again
stop being a jerk matt you're better
than that no i'm not first of all
how could you watch this show and think
that i'm better than being a jerk
have you not been paying attention at
all
um and he said well will my kids get the
shot of course because i don't want them
to be the vector that killed off grandma
as for consent
didn't you make the argument a few weeks
ago that kids didn't have don't have the
mental capacity of giving rational
consent
but for a covet 19 shot they need to
give their consent a bit duplicitous
matt
are you sure you aren't becoming a
democrat
your selective logic is beginning to
make you sound like one okay
a few things here first of all we were
talking yesterday about children who are
being signed up for their parents for
vaccine
trials okay so they're they're kind of
like the lab rats that are being
experimented on to find out
how it works with kids what the side
effects are how effective it is
um we were talking specifically about
that and no i would not sign my i would
not assign my kid up for any medical
trial
period i don't care what it is
but then what about once we get past the
trials and kids are getting it and
everything and it's been deemed
safe by the powers that be um well
a few things here first of all you say
we want to make sure they don't kill
grandma
grandma can get the vaccine hopefully
your grandma already has it
so they're already vaccinated and we
know that kids
the studies have shown not only are kids
far less personally affected by it but
they're far less likely to spread it and
carry it on
so what is the chance that an
unvaccinated child
child who is already very low risk first
for spreading
and and being affected by coping what's
the chance that they that they spread it
to a vaccinate it to a fully vaccinated
adult
and that that adult then gets very sick
what are the chances of that
now i don't know exactly that's the
point i don't know what the exact
percentage point chance is but it's very
very vanishingly low
we do know that
as i've been saying all week the cdc
says that uh something like
of all vaccinated people who have gone
on to to
get to actually contract the virus it's
like point zero
zero eight percent
so you're gonna you're gonna get your
kid vaccinated
on the point zero zero eight percent
chance
that they get someone sick it's actually
probably lower than that
because those those adults who were
fully vaccinated and got sick anyway
first of all how sick did they get
and um and who did they get it from we
could probably probably not children for
the most part
so you're probably talking about a less
than .008 percent chance
are you gonna inject this you know uh
substance into a child based on that
you're going to make your own decision
as a parent i can tell you me personally
as a parent
the answer is no you know as you all
know the daily wire has been growing
like crazy not only do we move the whole
company across the country we also
released our first feature film struck
up a movie deal with gina corrano
and launched a new talk show hosted by
candace owens all within the last six
months that's six months of activity
only imagine what we have to do next uh
we've been moving at the speed of light
over here that's why i'm
really excited for the future of the
company and all of us here at the daily
wire would like to express our gratitude
to you
our audience for making all of this
possible we want to continue to include
you in our future plans
every day on my show i talk about a lot
of amazing products and services and
things you can get from sponsors that i
love and use but we want to know
uh we want to get to know you better so
we could choose our sponsors with you in
mind
so that you know you're not wasting
we're not wasting your time we're
telling you about
sponsors that are really going to help
you and your life so please go to
walsh and fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little bit more about yourself
and to sweeten the whole experience
those of you that complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000 gift card
but you can only take the survey once
per daily wire show so
if you want to increase your chances of
winning a thousand dollars go listen to
ben shapiro michael knowles or andrew
clavin to get access to their
their surveys as well again my survey
link is dailywire.com
walsh we'd love to hear from you we'd
also love for you to watch uh
candace tonight don't miss tonight's
episode where she sits down with dave
rubin
and they discuss everything from the
recall election to caitlyn jenner's run
to replace him
and much more next week we're changing
up the schedule candace will stream on
wednesday
for an interview with a very special
guest guest that you're not going to
want to miss so
join and uh stream candace live on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on daily wire
and get 25 off a new membership with
code candace at dailywire.com
subscribe but hurry the deal is going
away soon so go there now dailywire.com
slash subscribe
now let's get to our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation today we must
discuss a story that in another time
in another place you would assume is
parody it starts with a man named kelly
donahue
a contestant on the now tribecas
jeopardy uh donahue on tuesday
appeared on the game show after his
third win
while being introduced by the host he
briefly flashed three fingers to the
camera you can see it
three fingers um signifying that he'd
won three times we know that this is the
meaning behind the three fingers because
the day before he had flashed two
fingers and before that one
now i'm no math ways but i'm starting to
sense maybe a pattern here
now if you're a normal person a
well-adjusted person you might see the
three fingers
not understand the context and not do
any research into the issue because it
doesn't matter
such a person the normal well-adjusted
type if you see someone hold up three
fingers
and doesn't know why we'll think oh well
i guess there's some banal reason why
he's holding them three fingers
hmm okay well i guess i'll just continue
on living my life now
but the problem of course is that we
live in a country overrun by people who
are not normal or well-adjusted many
people sadly
are emotionally stunted lunatics with
the iqs of doorknobs
and so the fact that a guy on jeopardy
held up three fingers became a problem
a controversy a source of outrage it was
decided by the doorknob clan
that kelly's three-finger salute was
actually a secret message
to his fellow white supremacists kelly
donahue
may seem like a mild-mannered jeopardy
contestant but beneath that facade he's
a skinhead and a terrorist
and we know this because he moved his
singer fingers in a certain
way that's what the mob decided
as the controversy grew a post appeared
on medium
purportedly from a group of former
jeopardy contestants almost
almost 600 former contestants apparently
signed this letter
denouncing kelly donahue for holding up
three fingers
again i'm not making this up this is not
a parody
this is real this is a lengthy letter
posted
apparently signed by 600 people
condemning someone
for arranging their fingers in a certain
way
the letter first condemned donahue for
apparently saying the word gypsy
on monday so the day before the three
finger um
uh assault he said the word gypsy in
response to a clue
um the word gypsy is now offensive
apparently
i'm not sure what else you're supposed
to call gypsies i also don't care but
the gypsy kerfuffle was not the biggest
problem as the letter says reading now
says quote
tuesday april 27th was a more widely
felt misstep
during his on-camera introduction kelly
made a gesture with his hand
that he has since claimed was an
indication that he had won three games
he had on previous episodes indicated
with one finger and two fingers
that he had won one in two games and no
reasonable person would have interpreted
those
gestures differently however this
gesture was not a clear-cut symbol for
the number three
he held his thumb and forefinger
together with his other three fingers
extended and palm facing inward and he
tapped his chest
this whether intentional or not
resembled very closely a gesture that
had been co-opted by
white power groups alt-right groups and
an anti-government group
that calls itself the three percenters
in a public facebook post that has since
been deleted kelly states
that's a number three no more no less
his public facebook profile also
features a cover photo of frank sinatra
making a similar gesture
this was either erased or made private
on wednesday morning along with hundreds
of public comments on his few jeopardy
related posts
regardless of his stated intent the
gesture is a racist dog whistle
some of the first people to notice this
were not affiliated with jeopardy in any
way they were viewers who couldn't
believe what they'd seen
captured it on video and shared it on
twitter among them were people of color
who needless to say
are attuned to racist messaging and not
appreciative that the show allowed this
symbol to be broadcast
oh but wait it gets dumber continuing
most problematic to us uh as a contest
as a contestant community is the fact
that kelly has not publicly apologized
for the ramifications of the gesture he
made
if something has been misconstrued an
apology and a total disavowal of any
connection to white supremacist doctors
is called for oh my gosh
we saw that gesture we saw that gesture
air on television
we are among the public it affected
and we are a diverse group of people
people of color
religious minorities and other
marginalized marginalized groups
already live in the united states and in
canada that have structural
institutional racism sexism
anti-semitism ableism homophobia and
transphobia
embedded into their history and function
these people deal with microaggressions
nearly every day of their lives
through words actions and assumptions
that remind them on a constant basis
that they are not the default they are
not the mainstream they are not real
citizens
and that is hard enough that is enough
for them to bear and enough for us to
keep trying to recognize to address and
to fight that is already a series of
walls and fences
that keeps us from from truly reaching
the american ideal
of e pluribus unum we cannot stand up
for hate
we cannot stand next to hate by the way
this is all still about the fingers okay
we cannot stand on stage with something
that looks like hate
we are ashamed to be associated with
brands and identities that suffer
the taint of hateful statements and
actions particularly if they go
unchallenged by those at the top
all right it's hard to know where to
begin
in dissecting this abject
madness in encountering the leftist
mindset i feel much as i feel when
walking into one of my kids rooms and
seeing the chaos of toys and debris
strewn all over the place i i don't know
where to begin
in cleaning it up fortunately i don't
have to i tell them to do it it's their
room knowing full well that they're just
going to stuff everything under the bed
i haven't i have a don't ask don't tell
policy on those sorts of things
just get the mess out of my sight i
don't care where it goes
mommy feels differently you know that if
she's telling you but for me just
i don't want to see it any case
back on subject in trying to sort
through the mess of leftist psychosis on
display here i suppose we could start
with the fact that
the three-finger symbol is not a white
power symbol and never was
the left simply decided at some point
that it is or should be
and announced that heretofore if you're
around if you arrange your fingers in
that way
you're a racist whether you meant to be
or not
and we could also note the truly
diabolical lunacy inherent in the idea
that intent doesn't matter the outraged
members of the contestant community
the newest marginalized group on display
on on the scene here maybe they'll get
added to the lgbt acronym
you know lgbtqia
cc for contested community but they say
that uh even if he didn't mean to flash
a white power sign he should still
apologize
for their misinterpretation
of course the truth is exactly the
opposite
if you wildly misconstrue someone else's
meaning and intent
and accuse them of saying something they
didn't say
it's you who should apologize you're at
fault
i don't have to apologize to you for
your false accusations against me
we might also mention the you know
incredible fragility demonstrated here
we hear so much about white fragility
but what can we say about a person
who feels traumatized and attacked
by the number three
and how do these people ever watch
sesame street
today's number is number three they go
screaming out of the rooms hide under
the bed
make it stop what is there to be said
about people who are suffering ptsd
because of the way a jeopardy contestant
positioned his fingers this is a
maniacal level of fragility
these are people who in saner times
would be committed to asylums
i'm not even kidding these are people
who should be in lunatic asylums
they are psychotic
now these are all things that we might
say if we wanted to defend kelly donahue
from these outrageous attacks
but i have a policy that i've told you
before about defending people from the
cancel mob i only defend
those who are willing to defend
themselves and there's a reason for that
i can't defend you if you're going to
kneecap me in mid defense by apologizing
for doing the very thing
that i was just defending and so i can't
defend donahue sadly
i can't defend him because of this which
he posted to his facebook yesterday
here's what he said
i'm truly horrified with what what has
been posted about me on social media
i absolutely unequivocally condemn white
supremacy and racism of any kind
people who know me personally know that
i'm not a racist but for the public at
large it bears repeating i am not a
racist and i reject and condemn white
supremacy in all forms of bigotry for
the evil they are
it's shameful to me to think anyone
would try to use the stage of jeopardy
to
advance or promote such a disgusting
agenda during the taping of my fourth
episode i was simply raising three
fingers to mark my third win
there was nothing more i was trying to
indicate i deeply regret
this terrible misunderstanding i never
meant to hurt a soul and i assure you
i am no friend of racist and white
supremacist i removed the previous post
because the comments were more than i
could bear
i stand by the statements itself and you
could find it reported in other media i
did however understand the fair
criticism
that i didn't include a forceful
condemnation of white supremacy
in my initial statement i hope my
feelings of that matter are clear now
okay well kelly
you're on your own bud with that you're
on your own
not going to get a defense you're not
going to get any sympathy
because i am tired of this i'm tired of
it
i know it can be overwhelming when
you've got thousands of people coming
after you accusing you of being racist
saying all things these things that
aren't true happens to me a lot
but but we we need to require of each
other
a little bit of a spine just a little
bit not asking for much
apologizing and and barking on command
like a dog
because these scumbags told you to
condemning white supremacy like there's
any reason for you to do it
as if there was ever any indication at
all that you're a white supremacist
no now i you know now i lump you in with
them
now i feel the same way about you as i
do about the rest of them i do
now here's the thing when you when you
apologize for something
you admit guilt
now you're not guilty obviously all you
did was hold up three fingers
but you've admitted guilt for something
you didn't do
because you can't apologize for
something you can't actually apologize
for something that you didn't do
right the apology doesn't mean anything
it's like if someone
you know if bob comes up to you and
tells you that jim
just punched him in the face are you
gonna say
uh oh i apologize for that what are you
you didn't do it what are you
apologizing for
or better yet because in this case
nothing happened at all it's better if
someone if someone comes up to you and
says that um
you know and and accuses you of sending
your invisible dragon
over to their house to uh burn it down
and you say oh oh i i apologize for that
no you didn't do it so by apologizing
you're admit it you can't in order to
apologize you must admit guilt
it comes with the territory inherent in
the apology
is it a mission of guilt and that's why
it becomes impossible to defend you
you said you were guilty basically
now the appropriate response to this
kelly is to say
to the people accusing you of this f you
uh i apologize for nothing you people
owe an apology to me
you lunatics and by the way i'm gonna
sue you
for defamation i need all of you
personally to apologize to me publicly
and beg for my forgiveness or i will not
stop until i
bankrupted you all in court that's what
the response should have been
but it wasn't so kelly donahue was
canceled all the people trying to cancel
him are canceled
and again we end the week with a with a
round cans a round of cancellation for
everyone
which is always a fun way to end it all
right we'll leave it there for today
and for the week have a great weekend
everyone see you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator
is mckenna waters the matt wall show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin